absolutely president biden said to sign
that massive 1.9 trillion dollar relief
bill
passed by the house without support from
any republican
we're about to pass a historic the most
progressive bill in american history and
the president will sign it
on friday we of course are moving full
speed ahead on the implementation of the
bill
because we know the american people need
help and need it as soon as possible
even though we have not spent a trillion
dollars of the help we already gave them
in december
are here to react louisiana gop center
budget committee member
senator john kennedy senator are you
celebrating the greatest
progressive bill in the history of our
country
well i i voted against it brian
president biden says it's a a
coronavirus bill
and uh my response is right
you know and the stripper really likes
you uh
i said the other day that calling this a
coronavirus bill is like
like calling harvey weinstein a feminist
it's just shock from a spending point
and the reports of it i like i like
trying to help people on absolutely
who are unemployed and i like trying to
help our small business people
especially our restaurants
but i don't understand why we have to
give bucket loads of money to prisoners
why do they need help uh i don't
understand why we have to give money to
people around our country
illegally i don't understand why we have
to give money
to states whose revenues have gone up
california
i don't i don't understand why we have
to give
130 billion dollars to to schools that
refuse to open
i don't know why we have to pay
reparations this bill has a reparations
provision
um and and and if you add up all the
corrode of our spending
and then all the spending porn there's
no comparison and to me
um using a coronavirus bill
to effectuate spending porn is like
looting after a natural disaster and
that's why i voted against it we tried
with president biden and he said look
i'll meet you halfway we said okay
well and then he he just ignored us i
mean
if if he if he was meeting us halfway he
said he's a damn poor judge of distance
it's comical to see these news these
news outlets
report that senator schumer and joe
biden are massive negotiators because
they came to a deal with cinema
and mansion have you forgot about the
other party that's called negotiation
and i'll just bring this up to you
though now we have an election in a year
and a half
and at that time people might be saying
themselves well one party gave me
fourteen hundred dollars and one person
gave me three hundred dollars
for per child under 17 for tax cut
are they are you concerned that this
money
will get them election victory no
because
i don't think the american people are
morons unlike some of my colleagues i
mean the american people don't read
aristotle every day they don't have time
they're earning a living
but they'll many of them most of them be
happy to get the money but
they understand that we're borrowing all
this money we don't even have five
percent of it
and what i would like to see is is uh
president biden call a press conference
and and answer these kinds of questions
but i think it's just
a shame that uh
i got to put this the secret service
heroically
jumps in front of president biden if i
knew if if a reporter tries to ask him a
question
it's unbelievable you know sometimes you
don't hear it he could walk away but
this time he stared right at the press
and walked away
real quick you're doing something i
think is great you're well you
are sponsoring bipartisan legislation
that allow digital
publishers and newspapers to
collectively negotiate with the
behemoths called google and facebook
and others that are taking the content
for free
and refusing to negotiate with the
outlets that are actually driving the
content
australia stood up to them and seemed to
have gotten money
what do you plan on doing well these
large social media platforms are trying
to swallow the world
they're not companies they're countries
they're taking the original content
produced by newspapers and by television
broadcasters they're not paying
the broadcasters or the newspapers for
it and they meaning the social media
platforms are putting it